[Musique]
je me disais que je pourrais rester
dormir chez toi après ta soirée
d'anniversaire et fit aussi ne pense
qu'à ça disait elle est chaude et elle
veut passer la nuit avec toi qu'est ce
que tu peux demander plus tranquille
[Musique]
j'ai un cadeau pour toi un pistolet de
détresse tuez vos meilleurs amis depuis
toujours il n'ya rien
bah là ça tangue parce que jamais arrivé
si on n'avait pas été bourré ce que tu
as fait avec balla ce n'est pas ce que
deux hétéros sont censés faire ensemble
qu'est ce que tu fais change de casiers
et pourquoi à ton ami francky
ton père est là tu sais je comprends
très bien ce que tu es je croyais qu
aujourd'hui il trouvait normal que les
jeunes explorer sexuel ce genre de truc
que vous faites entre vous
tu ne dois pas être étonné par son
attitude ges en fait des tonnes pour que
tout le monde sache que son petit copain
est hétéro campagne agricole
ici on arrive à l'école ensemble tu sais
qu'on risque d'en prendre vraiment plein
la gueule tous les deux
[Musique]
j'aime pas qu'on manipule et ma soeur
est reparti de cervelle pour faire
croire gt paquet tout change dans la vie
même les amitiés les plus solides
peuvent se défaire à ses parents
un adolescent est une expérience
sexuelle avec quelqu'un que tu aime
beaucoup
c'est peut-être que ça au fond
je te conseille d'être attentif à ce que
tu peux ressentir et de ne pas trop
embêté avec les éthiques pour l'instant
[Musique]